hopeful in Poland the city has around
120,000 residents and is the historical
capital of Upper Silesia the marketplace
and the PS tower are its landmarks the
marketplace is lined with the Rope town
houses they will rebuild after World War
Two the surrounding countryside is also
a fascinating place to visit taught both
I non I button is nagging shahnaz the
region around a pole has the largest
number of castles and palaces in all of
Poland Oh Paul is not only the capital
of the opal province it is also famous
as the capital of polish song anfiteatro
java version crave a festival polski
piosenki thanks to television every pole
is familiar with the sights of the PS
tower and the amphitheater the national
festival of polish song is held here
each summer many famous singers began
their careers in opal oh yes like that
nice first p value it's our country's
most important festival in 2013 we
celebrated its 50th anniversary with a
big gala than the doctor also more than
6 million viewers watch us on television
ah quiesce don't happen it's a tradition
to watch the festival together by
estoppel not rabbits yeah
ople province is also famous for its
porcelain in downtown opal you can find
the typical flower pattern ceramics in
every imaginable form opal exports
porcelain too many countries especially
to the Far East
it's all produced by hand
that's what about Mary ansa every
porcelain painter has his own particular
style Molly on circular medieval this
occur it's a kind of handwriting when
you put up half an hour from opal
tourists encounter an unusual
construction mozhno castle which dates
back to the 17th century was once the
home of a wealthy aristocratic family
then it served for decades as a
psychiatric hospital now it's open to
tourists yelling Roosevelt ashlyn schema
Polski Polski East many people call the
castle the Polish Disneyland okay that
may sound a bit kitschy but we like and
accept this description is now sitting
in Dundee snail and Jewish it's
available right beside the castle active
vacationers can go riding for about 13
euros an hour it's a great region for
riding lots of nature that's a metaphor
I like the stud farm the atmosphere here
is great the horses are wonderful and
the palace and surroundings are
beautiful zamak is fit Navy dokie nice
on the provinces second largest city
lies to the south only about 20
kilometers away from the czech border it
has had a colorful history owned at
various times by Poland and Germany even
the French were here in 1806 the sim
jacob and agnes church is mrs. greatest
site built in the early 15th century it
was later renovated in the neo-gothic
style
Lissa yeah Jesus was once called the
Rome of Silesia today we can call it the
Rome of tourists yes because everyone
finds something to his taste here in the
residents of the bishops or it's our
chance for biskup ego DJ Caruso is najib
the last stop on our tour is mounts in
an to the east of opal and Mesa
surrounded by Nature it's primarily a
religious site sedans Cathedral is home
to a Franciscan Order
on important holidays the mountain
becomes a place of pilgrimage
yes miss savient cover podcast amid the
mountain has other important aspects
quarter of him it has geological
formations and flora and fauna not found
anywhere else we let our day on mounts
and an come to a close with a typical
salesian meal beef with Sally's Ian
potato dumplings typical is a little
hollow in the potato dome it keeps the
source in the dumplings and the Alva
restaurant the servers still wear
traditional Sally's in dress Bon Appetit
you